Pro Football Hall of Famer NFL Fox on
Fox analyst Howie long back on the show
how are you how I I'm great how are you
I'm great thank you do you know is it
officially Vegas writers do you know
what do you know what does it happen I
don't know I you know there wasn't a
mass email sent down I I do know they
you know obviously the stadium is well
on its way and close to being done oh my
gosh this facility is close to being
done and you know having played in
Oakland and practiced in Oakland and
played in LA that year in 82 but making
that move and then the team making the
move shortly after I retired back up to
Oakland and now to Vegas I I'd say the
Southwest Raiders that's right there in
the area right around there we saw the
the latest photographs of that Stadium
like I mean if I ask you right now who
the starting quarterback is gonna be for
the Raiders next year first snap 2020 in
that Death Star who's gonna be what do
you think why there's so many rumors
about this well it's actually I've
gotten to text this morning about the
most absurd scenarios I could have
possibly heard Tom Brady all right it's
Brady right right right well did he text
you too no Texas probably Mayock saying
stop saying that stuff is probably Texas
from Mike it's kind of like you know you
look at the pictures of brocco bomb a
bomb obama and you know years one and
two and then look in your eight and you
know the aging process is right it's
just accelerated its accelerated at the
presidential position in the general
manager position well I don't know if
the death stars tapping our phones how
he or if your phone might be running out
but I'm here in similar to my phone and
captain's 81 you know is that Bradshaw
is tapping your phones now he's oh I
don't know so so what do you think is
gonna happen this coming weekend how you
got a big game coming up on Fox Sunday
afternoon Seahawks Packers it's it's the
game this weekend with the most
quarterback experience of any of the
games by far what do you think happens
real creative quarterback right
ya know III like it i it's gonna be
interesting because I I think both
quarterbacks are I think in a in a
unique position because I said you know
that's because of the injuries are
running back in Seattle and you know
bringing back Marshawn Lynch and I think
we'll probably see more Marshawn Lynch
this week and injuries to the offensive
line maybe really the the entire offense
is kind of put on Russell's shoulders
and you have the throw at the end of the
game to kind of seal the victory to the
calf is and that kid is pretty amazing
you know it's it's Al's philosophy of
bigger stronger faster I think you know
if you look that up in the dictionary of
being Metcalfe and all of a sudden he's
or he's a revelation and that's been
that's been a big big pickup for them
and the facet to that offense that
they've lacked for a while opposite
Lockett and uh you know will they get
people back you know will they get a
party back will they get you know brown
back that's big for them if they can do
that I think they'd like to you know of
course they'd like to run the ball
you know lean on Russell but run the
ball but last week you know their
inability to run the football put so
much pressure on on Russell and
Philadelphia because he's very good
stopping the run so
going on the road going to be loud your
defense defense gonna have to play great
versus a different kind of green be
offense you know I think Jones's has has
really become a I think the kind of
piece that maybe Aaron needs to you know
take it to the next step which you know
I know he's been trying to do for the
last few years that wrong game has been
I think changed the change the look of
the Green Bay Packers and you know new
offense and I known as a head coach and
we'll see how it goes part of that part
of that was you know I think maybe added
on its course with with Mike and Aaron
and and now it's on Aaron and and the
new offense and they made some additions
on defense that I think are really good
but we got to play the runner they could
play the run and force them into long
yardage situations up there it's a tough
place to play both from a weather
standpoint and and also a stadium stamp
when it's just you walk in it's like you
know it's the new Rockne you know sure
it's it's the ghosts it's the hallowed
halls if you will of Lambeau Field hey
how're your phone is beeping quite a bit
I'm gonna have you if you don't mind put
on hold and Mike tell to phone my sound
guys about to talk to you right there
let's see if how he's got like a cell or
or a or a speaker or something like that
to speak to how he's gonna call the how
he's gonna call back and see if we're
gonna do this b-plus he may be an
allegiance stadium that may be how its
ariados devout Davis is listening deaths
to the Death Star it really is
they clearly sat down and said we want
it to look like the Death Star hundred
I'm glad we absolutely
let's pray in the Vick but don't you
think the Vegas desert is gonna be like
a billion degrees or you take that and
you'd like the heat of a thousand suns
but here's the thing about an egg and
you add it you add it to the Al Davis
spike that still exists
I'll Davis I'm suddenly up out by the
way al Davis spike it'd be a great
fantasy to got me this alley back on
right now alright you give that you back
there Howie that better oh my god
I can it's so much better her back
thanks oh yeah well I'm up here on the
mountain and we do a little crank thing
to kind of Sarah Oh work is a hamster
it's the hamster on the mountain like
that okay but but he is Union so we we
have to give him a break and understand
yep enough and come up writer I just saw
an image of the Death Star go by how is
that stadiums great is that great
perfect it is perfect it's beyond
perfect how're you if you're gonna go
somewhere Vegas I remember and I forget
exactly when it was but a you know a
number of years ago market said to me
you know I'm gonna be a good owner I'm
gonna I'm gonna kill beat the team guy
and I'm going to do it I'm supposed to
do and you know put in the application
for Los Angeles and which is supposed to
be based on need and no team had a
greater need than then Oakland you know
when you consider the stadium and the
money and and all that the ability
inability to compete on the market right
place in that current situation and as
sad as it is having to move but I
remember him saying that at the time to
me that you know if if things don't work
out the way they're supposed to work out
and I do the right thing and they don't
do the right thing then I'm gonna take
the team to Vegas and I looked at Mike
was I just talking al so now is there
gonna be like a slot machine in the
stadium like a Raiders listen we've all
we've all kind the league is the door is
open it's it's cracked but it's open
yeah and and I think we're all you know
we're all going to be you know taking
part in in you know the
beginning stages of of that being a
bigger part of television broadcasts and
stadiums are going to have to deal with
it and when you think about how unique
that area is if you've got to come up
with a 750 million dollar relocation fee
so how do you do that what do they have
in abundance in Vegas hotel rooms yes
they do so you put a small tax on each
room for a period of time you raise that
money who's gonna know no one's gonna
know what's the number-one non-shared
revenue in the NFL luxury box
yes that's it the reason why everyone
makes a big deal out of stadiums you
know Jerry Stadium down in Dallas and
you know kind of set the bar certainly
high and that that stadium in Los
Angeles will be extraordinary but what's
unique about Vegas is who needs luxury
boxes in Vegas rich people whales the
whales need an ally yes the whales
he knows that's right so your Los
Angeles knocking on company's door or
saying game do you wanna do you want to
do a luxury box with a 10 year
commitment for $450,000 a year no I
don't know right the tax codes changed
I'm not sure it's like you go to mo
green he wants two of them you know what
I mean green that's a hey that's a great
name yes mo green no green one two and
he would get three but the problem is
this Fredo was doing something with
cocktails before before I let you go
last thing is who do you think you're
gonna see in Miami when you and the rest
of the Fox NFL on Fox crew does a
pregame show who you're gonna look at
the field and you're gonna see which two
teams what do you got well I think who's
at home who's been who's been dominant I
think San Francisco has gotten healthy
although I think Kansas City I think the
question is bigger in the AFC because I
think can
city is deep now they're healthy they
have redundant pieces at positions where
they didn't have redundant pieces on
offense so if one guy goes down you know
the offense doesn't suffer and it just
keeps rolling their defense is better
you think about the way that the New
York Giants triggered out under Steve
spagnolo when they won the Super Bowl
right there's two three games it was
horrible and and same thing in Kansas
City and they're kind of turning the
corner now I'm not saying they have the
the Michael Strahan OC human you're a
defensive front and talked and and that
whole group and what they did but
there's certainly a major improvement if
that piece shows up in the playoffs
they're gonna be tough to beat whether
it's in Baltimore or anywhere else but
San Francisco I would say healthy as
healthy as they've been if they get all
their pieces back they're playing at
home they'll be tough to beat okay and
before I let you go I know look your
kids are your own your own humans but
whatever you can share about Kyle do you
think we're gonna see him play again
Howie what do you think I'm not sure and
I don't think Kyle is really sure I
think where Kyle is let's think about it
here you know it's a we're working on a
reconstructed ankle that's one he had
his neck fused that's two I was there
doctor elet ROG did his elbow and
shoulder simultaneously and I was there
that night chasing him around the hotel
room with a bucket the things that
people don't see you know that that side
of the game which you know next shoulder
elbow knees ankle you know it's when
they say leave it on the field I mean he
certainly have done that so I I think I
think he deserves the right to take some
time and get right physically and figure
out where he is mentally and physically
and then make a decision and I think
that's where he is right now
how best to you Diann the whole long
family you're wonderful humans and I do
hope to see you on the set and in Miami
great great I appreciate it
of course and say hi to the gang there I
will yeah actually I told this story the
other day it's funny you remember when
you were on the first time on NFL
Network Super Bowl coverage down to
Jacksonville and you and Terry came
together and the Super Bowl Lombardi
Trophy was on our set and I ain't
pointed to it and I asked what's it like
to pick that thing up four times to
Terry and he got up to go pick it up and
a member of the security staff jumped in
to prevent them from doing it on live
television remember that one Howie oh
it's not great remember that's somebody
in a yellow slicker there's a lot of hot
dogs in Jacksonville in the second half
I don't want to indict a city but that
happened to you can't run out of hot
dogs a second
you know what Howie you're just spitting
truth thanks for the call we'll chat
soon we'll just be the man that's how he
long NFL on Fox for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app